[موسيقى]
صرخات
أم أخرى فقدت طفلها
[موسيقى]
حيتان عدد لا يحصى من الأمهات
والآباء تطارد غزة الآن، قُتل ما يقرب من 2000
طفل هنا خلال
أسبوعين وفقًا
لوزارة الصحة الفلسطينية،
عائلات مرعوبة من احتمال تعرضهم للقتل
بعد ذلك، يكتبون أسماء
أطفالهم على أرجلهم على أمل أن يتمكنوا من
التعرف عليهم وسط الفوضى، ويموت المزيد
كل يوم مع
تكثيف إسرائيل غاراتها الجوية على ما
تقول إنها أهداف لحماس في غزة حيث يعيش
أكثر من مليوني شخص.  نصفهم من الأطفال
محاصرون في هذه
الحفرة، وقد دعا الجيش الإسرائيلي مرة أخرى
جميع السكان إلى الفرار من الجنوب، وهو
أمر وصفته الأمم المتحدة سابقًا بأنه
غير إنساني وانتهاك محتمل للقانون
الدولي،
ولكن حتى أولئك الذين يمكنهم القيام بالرحلة بطريقة ما
تحت القصف وتحت
الحصار  لا تجد
مكانًا، هذا هو كان يونس في جنوب
القطاع، الموت يتبع العائلات هنا
أيضًا ولا يمكن لأحد أن يغادر.
حصار كامل لقد أغلقت الحدود الغذاء والماء
والإمدادات الطبية تنفد،
وأصبح البقاء على قيد الحياة أكثر صعوبة بسبب
ساعة [الموسيقى] المتوجهة إلى  المكان الذي يتعرض فيه
للتوتر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي، يقوم
الصحفي الفلسطيني م.ز بتوثيق عدد الضحايا من
الأطفال، وصفحته مليئة بصور
وجوه بريئة،
ضحايا صغار مرعوبين ومصابين
بالعنف، لا أحد هنا يستطيع أن يخبرهم متى
سينتهي، هل يمكن لأي شخص أن يخبرني
ماذا؟  لقد فعلوا ذلك ليستحقوا أن
يُقتلوا بهذه الطريقة،
أرجو أن يكون هناك أي سبب وراء
قتل أطفالي هؤلاء الذين يبلغون عامين أو ثلاثة أعوام
بهذه
الطريقة، هناك دعوات لتأخير
غزو بري بارز على الجيب من
الولايات المتحدة وجماعات حقوق الإنسان، لكن إسرائيل لا
تردع  قصف القطاع المضروب
بمئات الضربات الجوية الأخرى،
وهو مكان يعاني بطريقة ما
ويستعد الآن للمزيد